[Music]
joe runs the youtube channel naked
watchmaker where he restores vintage and
antique watches
this three thousand dollar cartier tank
watch was designed during world war one
this particular watch was made in the
1980s it was left in a damp cellar and
now the leather strap is deteriorating
dirt is caked inside the gold plating is
tarnished and the watch is not
functioning
joe shows us how he restores this watch
by taking it apart fixing the movement
which is the gears inside cleaning it
polishing the pieces gold plating the
body and reassembling it
first joe is deconstructing the watch so
he can work on each piece separately
he's using a screwdriver to carefully
remove the tiny screws
joe places each piece into small
containers to ensure he doesn't misplace
a part
[Music]
then he moves on to taking apart the
inside of the watch
[Music]
now as you can see this is a tiny
movement
it's a cartier 78-1
17 jewel manual wine movement
it's a very simple movement with just an
hour and minute hand
the movement is very dirty and there is
a screw missing on the train bridge
[Music]
joe uses tweezers and a screwdriver to
meticulously remove each component from
inside the watch
[Music]
then it's time for the cleaning he puts
each piece into metal mesh containers
and places them into an ultrasonic
cleaning machine
the ultrasonic waves clean the piece
without damaging them
for my case in bracelet cleaning i used
this water-based harmoniated solution
one tank with the solution and two rinse
tanks with just clean water
i then use these two non-water based
solutions for cleaning the movements
the gold plating on the case of the
watch has tarnished and worn off in some
spots so joe is replating it
he is polishing the body to blend in the
silver and gold areas
so the idea is to not remove all the
gold or just to blend it all in so that
it's level and then we can replate it
after polishing the change in color is
drastically different and most of the
scratches on the case are taken out
so you can see a few big dents here and
i'm going to leave them in because if
you try and take these out then you'll
end up ruining all these texts and
hallmarks and stamps so sometimes you
just have to know when to stop
[Music]
to replay the case of the watch joe uses
a mixture of chemical baths and a gold
plating tank
electricity from the tank fuses the gold
onto the piece
i first cleaned the part in an electro
cleaning solution which has violently
reacted with the silver
the reaction to the silver easily wipes
off
i then nickel activate the case just in
case nickel was used in the factory
silver does tarnish very easily
so even if there is gold plating on top
of it the tarnish on the silver will
eventually show through the thin layer
of coal plating so it's always a good
idea to put a layer of nickel on first
after nickel activating the case i then
nickel plate the case and give the
plating a quick buff to make the shine
even
and then i nickel activate it again and
then finish off with a layer of gold
plating
once joe has taken all the steps to
clean repair and replate this cartier
watch he starts reassembling it
he applies glue onto the inner edges of
the case then places the crystal back
onto the case and cures it under a uv
light
he strategically lays out all the inner
pieces to start putting the watch back
together
for that missing screw i have a similar
movement
[Music]
let's see if we can find the screw
we have a screw
joe accurately places each tiny part
using tweezers to reassemble the
movement
if he doesn't place each part in the
correct order the watch will not work
[Music]
he uses very thin screwdrivers to screw
in the small screws and keep everything
in place
[Music]
joe tests the watch's movement using a
time grapher which measures the ticks of
the watch to calibrate it
he puts the dial over the movement
attaches the hands onto the face
[Music]
puts the front and back of the case on
attaches a new leather strap
and the watch is complete and ready to
be worn for years to come
you